hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
if you've clicked on this video it's
most likely because you're about to play
the next entry in the God of War series
it may have been quite a while since you
last played a god war title and the
story may be a bit hazy so I thought now
is a great time to get up to date on
everything kratos has been up to
through his gore filled life so if
you're ready let's do this let's pick up
the story when Zeus the king of the gods
learns of a prophecy which will see him
killed by a mere mortal man
the prophecy also describes the
distinctive markings his murderer
possesses in fear of this marked warrior
Zeus informs his eldest children Ares
and Athena who also happened to be the
god and goddess of war and tasks them
with tracking down and ending this
potential threat whilst pillaging and
destroying the land Ares discovers a
small Spartan boy with extremely
distinctive birthmarks and attempts to
capture him that boy is not great oaks
it's his younger brother demos Kratos
tries his utmost to protect his brother
but he's no match for the God of War
Ares and his bitch-slapped into
submission
luckily for Kratos Athena persuades her
brother to leave Kratos alive because
not only is she the goddess of warfare
but she's the goddess of wisdom too
so her brother agrees and Kratos is
forced to watch on as his brother is
taken away fueled by his failure to
protect his younger brother
Kratos honors Deimos through a full-body
tattoo mimicking his brother's
birthmarks over time Kratos became a
member of the Spartan army hoping to one
day avenge his little bro his rage and
lack of mercy saw him ascend the Spartan
ranks eventually he married lissandra
and the two had a daughter named
Calliope he finally became a Spartan
captain after recovering a mysterious
healing element known as ambrosia in a
painstaking battle with Ulrich and the
barbarians he used this ambrosia to save
his daughter who was moments away from
death due to a plague ravaging the Lance
Kratos and his thirst for war soar the
Spartan army annihilate all opposition
until the day the barbarians returned
led once again by Ulrich
the barbarian hordes easily overpowered
and massacred the Spartans and all auric
needed to do was kill the defeated
Kratos with his final breath
Kratos called to the God of War Ares and
offered his life in return for victory
please destroy my enemies and my life is
yours seeing this as an opportunity to
build the ultimate warrior and disciple
Ares instantly slaughters the barbarian
hordes and binds Kratos to the blades of
chaos a constant reminder of his pledge
to the God of War
Kratos continued to murder and pillage
in the name of Ares and slowly lost his
humanity only his love for his wife and
daughter prevented Kratos from becoming
the ultimate weapon of war Ares desired
so knowing this arey said Kratos to
destroy a temple created to honor Athena
the village Oracle attempts to stop him
but consumed by rage and ambition Kratos
massacres all inhabitants but the final
two victims will haunt him for the rest
of his life
Ares have sent Kratos his wife and child
to that temple in the hopes he would
murder the only things keeping his
humanity alive and thus becoming the
ultimate weapon
Kratos now devastated finally realized
he could no longer serve Ares and vows
revenge for the murder of his family the
Oracle curses Kratos to wear the ashes
of his murdered wife and daughter for
the rest of his life
leading to his unwanted nickname The
Ghost of Sparta upon breaking his vow to
Ares Kratos is captured and tormented by
the Furies the Furies were effectively
oathkeepers who punished anyone who
broke a vow or promise the three Furies
kept Kratos in a dreamlike state almost
wiping his memories completely luckily
for Kratos Arcos who physically hauled
broken promises on his body in these
disgusting parasite like tumors saw the
injustice of his pledge to Ares and
assists him The Ghost of Sparta learns
the only way to be freed is to kill the
three Furies which he does with
surprising ease
[Applause]
with the job done our cult reveals that
Kratos must kill one last person to
truly free himself from the oath Arcos
himself as he's the son of the Furies
all the oaths were transferred over to
him Kratos slightly reluctant does the
dirty deed the truth of the merchant who
committed the slaughter of his wife and
child
the carnage forged from his relentless
ambition yes indeed Kratos his memories
fully returned and once again he is
ravaged by the death of his wife and
child poor guy he just can't catch a
break
now fueled by a desire to remove his
nightmares
Kratos meets Persephone the queen of the
underworld who offers the Ghost of
Sparta a better alternative seeing his
daughter again but that comes with a
caveat he must give up all his godlike
powers which Kratos agrees to Kratos
reunites with his daughter but the
happiness is short-lived Persephone
reveals she has Unleashed Atlas a
hulking great Titan who will destroy the
pillar that cradles the earth killing
all mankind and the gods of Olympus
of course Kratos can't stand for that
and gives up his life with his daughter
and once again goes on the warpath
against Persephone and Atlas jutsu Atlas
his size Kratos ops to chain him to the
upper edges of the underworld whilst he
returns to finish Persephone as she dies
her body explodes and the resulting
force destroys the pillar
luckily Atlas is still chained into
place and now holds the world on his
shoulders for the rest of time Kratos
once again commits himself to serving
the gods in the hopes of having his
memories removed but after a decade of
servitude he is a little pissed off to
say the least
and let's the gods know 10 years of it I
have faithfully served the gods with
when will you believe me of this
nightmare
Athena hears his calls and proclaims
that if Kratos can kill Ares the God of
War she will take his nightmares away
Kratos is more than happy to oblige
gaining revenge and losing his visions
are all he has ever wanted so off he
trots to Athens to face Ares and his
army
Kratos meets the local Oracle who
reveals the only way to defeat a god is
through a mystical item known as
Pandora's Box which so happens to be
chained to another great hulking Titan
called Chronos
Kratos does what Kratos does and murders
his way to Pandora's box and just before
he's about to open it Ares who feels a
disturbance in the force
sorry wrong franchise Ares sent his
kratos and hurls a pillar a few thousand
miles away in paling kratos almost
touching distance away from the artifact
he needs to kill Ares death is only the
beginning for Kratos after a long
journey through the underworld he gets
back to Athens to finally open Pandora's
box and becomes mega Kratos a huge
version of himself and fights Aries
Aries uses powerful memories of Kratos
killing his own family to gain the edge
in battle but Kratos driven by revenge
bests him and kills the God of War
Kratos who has now fulfilled his vow of
vengeance once again asks for his
memories to be removed but Athena is
having none of it no man no God could
ever forget the terrible deeds you have
done a broken and frankly devastated
Kratos takes himself to the highest
mountain in all of Greece the Ghost of
Sparta throws himself to his certain
death but the gods had a greater vision
for his future and to send him to
another level you will not die this day
Kratos from that moment on Kratos became
the new
God of War sat on his new throne Kratos
has a vision and travels to the Temple
of Poseidon to seek answers once there
he finds his mother dying who reveals
his brother Deimos is still alive and is
being held captive by Thanatos the god
of death and with that
Kratos his mama dies now back in Sparta
great Oakes battles his younger self and
reclaims his Spartan army from the pre
God of War days the god of war goes on
yet another murder spree and locates the
gateway to deaths domain here we finally
see Deimos who has the sexiest beard
I've seen in a long time and once free
demos reveals his anger for Kratos is
the only thing that kept him alive and
attempts to kill his brother during the
fight between the brothers Thanatos
takes demons away as he wants to be the
one who kills him but just in time
Kratos arrives and saves his brother
that becomes the catalyst for the two to
work together and the brothers take down
the god of death but at the cost of
Deimos his life Kratos once again has
lost his family and carried his brother
to his final resting place and Ponder's
his actions to which the gravedigger
calls Kratos
the destroyer of cars
Athena appears once again and attempts
to reward Kratos for his deeds as he has
no ties to the mortal world after his
daughter wife brother and mother are all
dead he can now become a full-fledged
God
Kratos shocks everyone and turns down
the offer and remarks of God's will
with his Spartan army at his back kratos
wages war on pretty much anyone he can
to spread the glory of Sparta the gods
watching on are becoming nervous of his
actions and Athena begs Kratos to stop
before he faces the wrath of the gods
Kratos defend is back on Athena both
physically and metaphorically and joins
his army in Rhodes but suddenly a
portion of his powers are stolen by this
mythical bird and given to the Colossus
of Rhodes the two behemoths battle on
and out of nowhere the king of the gods
Zeus throws down the blades of Olympus
the most powerful weapon in existence
the only downside is that Kratos must
infuse his last remaining godly powers
into the weapon to defeat the Colossus
of Rhodes it worked surprisingly well
and as he defeats the Colossus the
flailing arm crushes Kratos causing him
to drop the sword Kratos is now moments
away from death and must regain the
sword to become his immortal self again
lo and behold the mythical bird flying
around was in fact Zeus who reveals this
whole thing was a trick to kill Kratos
so Zeus shoves the sword straight
through Kratos killing him of course in
Greek myths death doesn't really mean
much and as Kratos is pulled into the
underworld he is rescued by another
Titan
Gaia Gaia and Kratos hatched a plot to
defeat Zeus by using the loom of fate
which effectively is a time machine he
ventures to the island of creation and
defeats countless foes and finally
locates the loom and attempts to change
his fate arriving back in time at the
moment he was killed by Zeus Kratos
takes the Blade of Olympus and the to
fight to the death
just as Kratos is about to land the
killing blow Athena jumps in the way and
is killed by Kratos in her last words
she reveals you
is Olympus meaning that if Zeus dies
Olympus will fall and all the gods will
perish but she isn't done there no son
should destroy his own father yeah
Kratos is the son of Zeus who'd have
thunk it no I have no father Kratos is
not flustered by the revelations and
once again uses the luma fate to build
his army filling it with Titans from the
past a huge war breaks out as the Titans
attempt to climb Mount Olympus a key
battle is won when Gaia and Kratos
defeat for Sidon but actually flood the
entire world in the process once a top
of the mountain Zeus lays in wait and
knocks Gaia and Kratos to their death
Gaia manages to hold on but refuses to
help Kratos revealing herself to be just
as untrustworthy as those pesky gods now
dead again Kratos is in the underworld
for the fifth time but this time he
defeats Hades the god of the underworld
whilst here Kratos learns how to defeat
Zeus and it's once again by using
Pandora's box but this time though it's
locked behind the flames of Olympus
which can only be extinguished by its
namesake Pandora once Pandora is located
Kratos his humanity finally kicks in
again and he sees her like a daughter he
lost when the moment arrives for Pandora
to sacrifice herself to extinguish the
flames of Olympus Kratos won't allow it
eventually she does break free but
another god stands in her way
Zeus father and son Zeus and Kratos
fight which is punctuated with Pandora
attempting to complete her task in life
her last-ditch attempt is foiled by
Kratos who refuses to lose another
daughter but one final insult from his
dad don't fail her like you failed your
fan
cut things into motion which can never
be undone after waking Kratos opened
Pandora's box to reveal well nothing
it's it's empty
this anticlimax is taken to the next
level as kratos and zu stand over the
now ruined flooded and destroyed world
they have created face before it it's
time to end this yes it's time remember
Gaia
well she managed to hold on and finally
reaches the summit again and attempts to
kill both Zeus and kratos during the
scuffle both gods fall into Gaia's chest
and fight next to her heart in the final
moments kratos kills both his father and
Gaia by impaling their hearts
simultaneously Kratos has now defeated
all the gods and all the Titans the
Greek pantheon is no more but wait Zeus
somehow transcended his body and his
spirit form attempts to kill kratos once
again using a mixture of fear violence
and those memories Kratos ate so much
but after 10 years of this living
nightmare Kratos is able to knock Zeus
his spirits back into his body and then
beat him to death in a lovely touching
father-son moment Athena
arrives in her new ascended form and
gives us one last revelation Pandora's
box did actually contain something it
contained evils such as fear which
envelops the gods but there was also an
even more powerful weapon inside that
box and that was hope which sounds
ridiculous but helped Kratos achieve his
ambitions to defeat the gods of Olympus
Athena asks for hope to be returned to
her so she could give it to mankind but
Kratos looking at the devastation around
him refuses her offer and does this
instead
and angered Athena removes the sod and
leaves Kratos to die his final death the
story isn't quite over yet though as
Kratos his body is no longer here and a
trail of blood leads over the cliff edge
you could call it a cliffhanger ending
see what I did there
sorry we now know that in 2018 the God
of War has moved into Norse myth in
which Kratos becomes a dad again but
this time he has a spectacular beard to
protect him
boo boo we did it I can't believe we got
through that I imagine from Playstation
grenade thank you for sticking around to
the bitter end
it's been an absolute pleasure I'll see
you next time